una reunión atípica después de que el
coi 19 obligó a los líderes mundiales el
año pasado a pronunciar sus discursos
desde la distancia en esta versión
aunque la asamblea general de la onu
tendrá delegaciones reducidas se espera
la presencia de más de 100 jefes de
estado y de gobierno la gestión de la
pandemia será uno de los ejes de la
reunión el secretario general de las
naciones unidas antonio guterres recalcó
la necesidad de revertir la desigualdad
en la distribución de las vacunas
mientras que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden promovió una reunión virtual con
los líderes mundiales para impulsar la
repartición como un llamado al mundo
para que se movilicen detrás de un plan
de vacunación que duplique la producción
de vacunas para llegar al 70 por ciento
de la población mundial a mediados del
próximo año
otros de los temas principales es el
cambio climático el primer ministro
británico pidió que los países
desarrollados se comprometan con donar
100.000 millones de dólares anuales para
financiar las acciones climáticas en
países en vías de desarrollo y el mundo
en vía de desarrollo es el que está
soportando la peor parte del cambio
climático en forma de huracanes
incendios e inundaciones
se prevé que la crisis en afganistán
también sea tratada para definir cómo
gestionar la situación del país y el
envío de ayuda humanitaria la asamblea
sea en medio de tensiones que opacan las
conversaciones que se llevarán a cabo
esta semana como la crisis de confianza
por el acuerdo august entre estados
unidos gran bretaña y australia que dejó
por fuera francia y las relaciones entre
china y eeuu alas que guterres calificó
de disfuncionales